the world is headed for stagflation next  year that's according to the latest  Bloomberg survey of professional and  Retail investors what's that collection  anyway it's a scenario when inflation  remains above average even as growth  slows that would be a nightmare for the  Federal Reserve and other central banks  that have spent most of this year  deploying jumbo rate hikes to rein in  inflation in a stagflation scenario that  would mean that those rate hikes will  have been ineffective in curbing prices  even as economic demand slows about a  third of investors are even more  downbeat and expect a deflationary  recession which means that both economic  output and prices fall meanwhile they  see plenty of risks in housing markets  most investors expect a 20 Plunge in  house prices in a major economy globally  with Canada and the UK seen as the most  vulnerable to this risk overall one  thing's for sure 2023 is a year for the  pessimists  [Music]